In Iran, the court sentences an American of Iranian descent, Amir Mirzai Hekmati,...
... to death on charges of spying for the CIA.
In Iraq, despite recent attacks targeting pilgrims,...
...thousands of Iranians cross into southern Iraq to attend religious rites in the holy city of Kerbala.
In Poland, a prosecutor is in stable condition after shooting himself...
...following a news conference he held...
...in relation to the plane crash that killed Poland's president two years ago.
In New Zealand, a light sheen of oil...
... extends about three kilometers from a wrecked cargo ship that split in two over the weekend.
In China, ice sculpture teams from nine countries...
... compete at the International Ice and Snow Festival in Harbin, China's Ice City.